Rogers hello Roger no surprise looking
like a million bucks yes
throwing the Nixon peace signs in the
air we were gonna wear a suit for you
today we did promise and honestly we
forgot our one guy Anthony did remember
we didn't we planned it before you both
wear the suit that's right it makes you
look better if we don't wear our suit
right exactly that's what that's what we
thought
now we add a theory about your book
around the office we compared your book
right yes two books of similar width and
size and notice because of the of the
textures of the pages your book is
considerably heavier did you purposely
make a heavier book so that people would
be like this is a much more substantial
read no is heavier because it people
will keep this for a lifetime I want it
to wear well I see everything you need
to know to succeed in life whether it's
politics business fashion style is in
this book and therefore I think it's
gonna become dog-eared people are gonna
be referred to it constantly I wanted to
hold up you wanted to have cookies it is
actually really good pace the reason a
lot of books don't have photo pages
because it's expensive to print exact
it's a really good paper so I didn't
want to go with some cheap foolscap you
know where I go something that would
last now there's a photo there's an
illustration in here of you dressed like
the Pope yes who wore it better you or
Rihanna good point I think there's a lot
of kind of funky pictures in there most
of them are things that people have sent
me mm-hmm you know this kind of comes
out of the Twitter world sure so I think
they're cool I kind of my included them
you know I mean there is the Joker for
example remember the Joker is the one
who says that's the thing about chaos
it's fair right so you know I like to I
like to foment a little revolution I
like to to upset the establishments
applecart your name has been on the
front page of The Drudge Report the
other day they were saying is he gonna
be involved in Muller's probe and how
much are you really in this like how
much do they do they think they're going
to get on you it's a it's a fascinating
question if I didn't know how the fake
news works I guess I'd be more concerned
if you look at that story it's a CNBC
story they say that Robert Mueller the
special counsel is probing my dinner
s with Rick gates a low-level Trump
campaign staffer who worked for Paul
Manafort he's also looking into our
meetings at Trump Tower and it points
out that gates and I worked together at
the legendary firm black mare mana 14
stone in the 80s I've had dinner with
the guy once in a restaurant with four
other people from the New York Trump
campaign to talk about the apportionment
of delegates to the convention the
number of meetings he and I had at Trump
Tower that would be zero the number of
meetings I had with him anywhere that
would also be zero no I can't think of
any time I was alone with him at least
not that I recall I did meet him at the
convention and he never worked at black
man forts ten stone he evidently worked
for a successor firm with a different
name after I sold my interest and moved
on several years after in fact I don't
think he met Paul Manafort till 2006 so
probing my relationship with gates will
be a short probe because I my contacts
with him during the campaign are minimal
and they're generally logistical or
innocuous as in tell that man afford to
return my phone call would you I was
kind of it at what point do you like
like what when did you stop being
surprised when when did you realize like
wow the press is really full of [ __ ]
here's the thing that it is a kind of
shock may is it the way they just keep
recycling the same chestnuts let's come
up with the most obvious answer gusoff
'red 2.0 I read you're friends with him
yeah exactly
first of all I can't I was in contact
with him over a twitter feed not exactly
the place to go not very oh oh seven
right
our entire exchange has a total of 24
words in it and it takes place six weeks
after WikiLeaks has already published
the documents that they're accusing me
of working with to to hack and provide
to WikiLeaks chronologically impossible
unless one has a time machine and Putin
hasn't lent me his time machine and well
did they what about
this the idea that well if he's tweeting
with gusoff her one can believe that
they had a relationship prior to the
tweets right so produced all the other
communications in Ronnie form they don't
exist
I'm gusoff er if this person really
exists first of all he's a Russian we
don't know that there are thumb prints
that are left in his computer is online
activities that are made to show that
he's a Russian but we don't know that
they're so clumsy they look to me like
they're planted he's using software that
is registered to a person who works at
the Democratic National Committee goose
and and his identity becomes public
guess what day the day the DNC announced
they've been hacked except for they
weren't hacked because the FBI has never
been allowed to see their server so
they're only allegedly hacked oh now he
did go online and say and predict this
was coming which is why I initially did
think he was the hacker I wrote that in
a column I changed my mind I also wrote
that in a column and that's what I said
to the House Intelligence Committee
under oath can you believe the so just
to wrap this up based on content context
and timing my 20 forward exchange with
goose for 2.0 is meaningless right now
can you believe the the the games of
semantics that have been going on with
the evidence quote-unquote that's
surrounding you I was watching a CNN
interview that you just did to promote
the book where they were bringing up the
tweet where you said something about the
Podesta's yes except you would put a '
in Podesta's but you also had the word
though so like so like you're sitting
there and like you and Chris Cuomo
arguing and you're saying it says the
Podesta's so it's referring to multiple
Podesta's and he's like but there's an
apostrophe in there so that means it's
Podesta a possessive you're going but
the camp I mean you're arguing over
which the apostrophe or the apostrophe
well I know people called him da Donald
but nobody ever called John Podesta
that's not a length so and and taking
the word V out material chaima t really
changes the intent of
of the tweet right the point of course
is nowhere did I ever say quote John
Podesta's emails will be hacked you'll
see them soon right because I had no
advanced knowledge of the alleged
hacking of his emails that's if they
weren't downloaded to a zip drive and
taken out the back door of the DNC as
many of us suspect and then there was
that terrific piece in the Nation
magazine in which a bunch of these
former CIA counter telogen s-- IT
experts said actually most of the
forensic evidence points not to a hack
but to the fact that the stuff was
downloaded to some zip drive or portable
drive because the download times are
evidently more consistent with that do
you think I have to ask you to often
subject to do you think that Giuliani is
doing a great job as a doing being a
legal spokesperson I think that I that
on the question of the of the deep state
coup d'etat and the legitimacy of mr.
Mueller and his and his rogue operation
Rudy's doing a great job on the question
of Michael Kohn and and stormy Daniels
not so much how did that happen like how
does it happen where he goes out like
because he also was like this and
pointed out the heel also went out and
said yeah he said we're gonna you know
try to get Muslims like it really just
kind of says this stuff it's like how
does that get to that place where the
president trying to stop it yeah where
Trump doesn't go don't say like he was
been watching the news and hit the roof
when he saw that well look I like Rudy
and I think bringing him in is a good
idea because he's a very smart smart guy
but more importantly he's a tough guy
and right now the president needs some
tough guys his lawyers remember what
told him mr. president don't worry about
this Miller thing we'll have it wrapped
up by Thanksgiving last year mr.
president don't worry about this Mueller
probe we're gonna have a letter from him
by Christmas then it was I think it's
coming right after New Year's now we're
into May and all of that has been proven
to be false so there were actually some
who say why don't you just sit down with
Mueller for an interview and you can
clear the air on this whole thing once
the New York Times published the list of
intended questions starting with when
did you stop beating your wife right I
mean if there aren't a good answers to
the way those questions are struck
they're all those type of questions so
if that doesn't tell the president that
they're out to get him it has nothing to
do with Russia it has to do with
reversing the results of the last
election Hillary's butthurt and she
wants it back
his part of it thoroughly is the
president hard to give bad news too like
he seems to get got it doesn't like to
hear but are some of them and again
they're not doing the right thing but
are they afraid to come and tell him
something like look this is gonna drag
out for a while because they're afraid
of just being booted no I actually think
that they were naive lawyers this isn't
a legal proceeding this is a political
proceeding with a legal subtext those
guys are lawyers so they're looking at
the case and they're saying this will be
easy to wrap up Joe there's no evidence
here not understanding that Mueller
doesn't need evidence that they're
running a campaign of innuendo and smear
with this story about Rick aides where
could that have come from so they leaked
which is a violation of their ethics and
the rules and then to try to change the
public narrative you may remember that
they gave the fake dossier to mike is AK
off of Yahoo so he would write it and
then they took his story to the judge
and said you see judge people are
talking about this that's other thing
dude that's how they operate yeah what
do you think happens I mean didn't you
think the Trump was gonna be out by a
certain point but they haven't been able
to get him out do you think he's gonna
make it through the four years that's
entirely up to him I would argue that
with 3% economic growth and peace
breaking out in the Koreas historic
achievement yeah and I think he's I know
that he is up to something in terms of
the Middle East he's working very hard
behind the scenes to try to find a
solution a peace solution for the Middle
East that would be the that would be the
Daily Double of diplomatic triumphs it's
going to be very hard to get rid of him
on the other hand he has the power right
now he needs to fire mr. Rosenstein he
needs to fire mr. sessions he needs to
he needs to pardon everybody in question
and then dared them to impeach him by
the way I just got back from Korea with
the peace deal
so now fire wise fire Jeff sessions
because Jeff sessions is the is the he's
the evil Keebler Elf he is all he's
interested in his marijuana really he's
obsessed with marijuana we have to
arrest everybody who's smoking marijuana
oh good people don't use marijuana he's
told the Senate no senator sick people
use marijuana right millions of it and
it helps them more than opioids so what
Big Pharma pal is he helping out here or
is he just a caveman a hillbilly do you
think that in Trump's Trump is as
clearly come out against opioids do you
think that he's gonna make it easier for
people to get legal marijuana I'm in an
effort to I think it's really important
to review the history on this the
president said in the campaign very
clearly that this was an issue for the
states to decide and if the states
decide they want medical marijuana they
should have it now he didn't endorse
medical marijuana himself he said it's a
state decision that essentially is
consistent with the Cole memo which is
the one thing Obama did that I agreed
with which declared that in the twenty
nine states where marijuana had been
legalized that the feds would stand down
on laws against possession and
distribution and so on good public
policy the first thing he did as soon as
he was out from under congressional
restraint the Rohrbacher amendment he
repealed the coal amendment so any
prosecutor in the country in a state
where marijuana is legal let's say they
want to run for governor and get their
name in the paper they bust the local
dispensary and you're on page one this
is bad this is a bad idea for many
months I spoke to the president about
this and he was surprised that Jeff
sessions was moving actively against
state legalized marijuana which tells me
his new summaries are being sanitized
right okay so we didn't show that to the
president he can't be expected to
negotiate with the Israelis and the
Saudis and the Egyptians and also read
everything that's in the newspapers
because he's on the phone constantly
doing his own kind of diplomacy he's
watching Fox and Friends every morning
too he's busy got to get new somewhere
exactly
so in this case sessions was misleading
him roughly two weeks ago the president
came out in an agreement with senator
Cory Gardner of Colorado that he will
now push to protect state legalize
marijuana through federal legislation I
think Jeff Sessions is checkmated the
president view I think is going to hold
here and now the question is how do we
get the President to move marijuana off
the schedule one list where it doesn't
belong that's that's the next goal but
he's got to get rid of that little
Keebler Elf in order to get any of that
it would be a it would be a side benefit
of canning this guy who looks at the
Clinton Foundation and tells the
Congress I could I don't see any crimes
this guy's got the visual acuity of
Stevie Wonder Rodgers book promoting our
stones rules it's really a beautiful
book you're very easy read like you know
each page has a rule on it and it's
really great let me ask you about the I
mean talking about stones rules because
it's about fashion or not just about in
lifestyle and politics and everything
why did you never switch to a slim cut
suit you're the only guy left that's
wearing saggy suits this is no let's be
clear this is not baggy it is full cut
yeah okay but there's not many of you
left it because because muscular guys
don't look good in in thin cuts excuse
me because all those squats my thighs
will not fit in a pair of regulation
riding boots uh-huh or in a pair of slim
cut jeans that was a nice sample I was
wrong I said his thighs are too muscular
and Sam said that's not the point is if
I wore a slim cut suit because of the
size of my chest it would gap but that's
hours in the gym doing you know better
prices right but you didn't think the I
mean there's still some fabric that will
be taken off now or do you just prefer a
backyard cot or or our loser cot or I
don't name it it's about the silhouette
okay all right let me Roger standing up
now you just put rise mics we've been
here I want to hear on the idea is the
line of the trouser between the suit
jacket and the trouser right so yeah
therefore cut but the point is they hang
they're not cinched and it creates that
that illusion also this is a very
soft shoulder there's no padding in here
it's a more natural shoulder it makes a
man look athletic not skinny you also
like to be comfortable let's be really
honest suits can be uncomfortable and
you probably like if you're sitting
there to be comfortable a subject to
breathe absolutely I like mine to be
that's why I always take it out now
let's say Barbara Bush you tweeted that
yes I've never met her obviously was she
just was she a nasty person hurt she's a
nasty drunk that's right this is based
on personal experience not some faraway
speculation I manage the New York New
Jersey and Connecticut primaries for
governor Ronald Reagan against her
husband then ambassador George Bush we I
sculpt them in New York they didn't get
a single delegate I beat the hell out of
a mini Jersey they didn't get a single
delegate delegate and in Connecticut
George Bush's home state where his
father was the US senator they carried
three congressional districts we carry
three congressional districts and the
delegate split was 16 Bush 15 Reagan Jim
Baker who was managing George Bush's
campaign but who I was very friendly
with warned me stay away from Barbara
she hates you I went to a big reception
when Bush was vice president president
was there President Reagan the entire
staff she saw me from across the room
and she made a beeline for me
she was bombed she stuck her finger in
my face and said I hate you oh now this
is not the warm wonderful woman you saw
depicted in all the funeral cut right
she was a nasty vindictive person to me
personally we try to remember people at
their best though no I admit that my
timing was probably not the best right
but to be clear I was overheard in a
restaurant in Austin Texas and what I
said was Barbara Bush drank so much
booze if they cremated her her body will
burn for three days I don't see it's
okay and I probably should have left it
at that but so so what people say what
are you saying she's a drunk no I
experienced it but results it's also
well known in Republican political
concerns now in retrospect right
my timing was probably not the best and
I am a Christian so may she rest in
peace
yeah II thought you were overheard you
didn't mean that to be publicly consumed
no but I shouldn't have doubled down and
confirmed it you should have kept yeah
you did double down on a pretty hard but
one of stones rules speaking ill of the
dead is not on that list well put it
this way it's the only thing worse than
being wrong or making a mistake is being
boring so I got not to be that's
exciting it's very very exciting yeah do
you say things sometimes just when you
feel like I have to say this a certain
way where people are gonna grab it like
if I just kind of say it factually it's
not as interesting but if I spiced it a
little bit people will run with it
exactly that that's that's called
dramatization so what I'm in the famous
iconic speech now and before the brown
Republicans and I say I have
communicated with Asajj and I say it's
through a back channel wow that sounds
very James Bondish back channel
confirming source intermediary all the
same thing but there's some
dramatization I was talking to a crowd
of 600 people but dramatisation is not
in accuracy everything I said was true
I see technically and that's important
so I feel like we've been following this
is Roger stones buddy with buddies with
Julian Assange as you know gusoff er is
he responsible for WikiLeaks all this
stuff for like a year and a half right
do you enjoy that this story just keeps
going and going it's tedious that's my
point is in other words it's brought up
by by irresponsible fake news outlets
like The Daily Beast and and Salon and
slate and sadly the Washington Post and
then you respond to it in the detail I
have here today assuming well that's
that I explained it and then three
months later they bring it back like
they never heard it right yeah it's the
fake news news cycle it's a tactic and
unfortunately like the birds on the
telephone line once one jumps off they
all jump off so the Washington Post
writes to close associates that's false
of Roger stone say that he told them
that he dined in London with a sighs one
weekend and one of them
says he has an email in which stone
predicted stone said the WikiLeaks
emails will be about Hillary Donna
Brazil and John Podesta
I call the Post reporter so you saw this
email right no no it's been described to
us they described my email yeah I know
the name of the two guys neither one of
them would be considered an associate of
mine one of them is a is a nasty critic
of mine online it was a nut job right
and the other guy I could disclose it
same nut Berg I mean number right I
remember him how is Sam doing now he had
a bit of a job let's call the Betty Ford
Center and find out if every is is the
attorney is dealing with his demons and
I'm and I and I wish you the best
know your as you were his mentor at one
point right well that's called that's
called smothering someone in your
embrace I think Mueller whatever you do
don't look at Roger stone he's innocent
I mean please Sam you're doing Steve
bannon's
you know legwork here a man who dresses
out of a dumpster
[Laughter]
you know Sam is he's all over the place
they've got something on the president
they've got nothing on the president I'm
not gonna listen I'm not gonna obey the
subpoena I'm an officer of the court of
course I was gonna be I mean this guy he
has a screw loose
sadly Israel way back to oh sorry way
back and I can't remind everybody I got
him his job with Trump and I got him
rehired after he got fired so let oh no
kindness go unpunished in your world in
politics so many things are said so many
people are friends and then they hate
each other and then this one doesn't
vote a certain way
is there a like a way back for Steve
Bannon in that world or no there's not
know which is which is different than
everybody else because look I had my own
falling-out with down from over Eliot
Spitzer he thought Eliot was a great guy
so much for that right and then we
reconciled after that we didn't talk for
two years he was furious at me for my
opposition and role in the removal of
Eliot Spitzer the the Eric Schneiderman
of his day
Eric Schneiderman seems to work much
worse much worse much worse so but you
know we were reconciled and he hired me
as a consultant for his 2012 exploratory
efforts hired me as a consultant on this
campaign until I resigned to do my own
thing I did resign I showed the
resignation letter to a New York Times
reporter and a Miami Herald reported the
night before because I knew somebody
would dispute whether I had resigned or
been fired and it's water under the dam
but I was about to publish the clintons
war on women mm-hmm and I didn't want
people to say oh that's Trump's book
right I see so what do you I mean go
make the Steve banning and why is he
unique so here's why he's unique there's
the one thing one cannot do in Trump
world I elected Donald Trump it's not
him it's me I'm the puppeteer right I
mean Donald is he's awful it's all my
brilliance once banned his picture was
on the cover of Time magazine is the man
who made Trump and let's be clear nobody
made from but Trump you can try to help
him if you're loyal to him you're trying
to serve him well he'll listen to advice
but he's not obligated to take your
advice
just because George W Bush did
everything Karl Rove told him to do
doesn't mean that Donald Trump is
controlled by others he'll listen but
he's his own man you know decisions W is
clearly controlled by others Karl Rove
yeah W has trouble putting together a
sentence oh yeah so he's a he's a
manifestation of karl rove in the bush
the Bush family political financial
means and all this talk about their
careers we talked about it a lot about
him being possibly like Kim Jong Un's
going no is my desire for peace but the
South Korean president was saying that
he should be nominated for a Nobel Peace
Prize how much of this is really Kim
jong-un being literally afraid of Trump
and say I better do something and make
peace you know I think this is a
manifestation of what Nixon and
Kissinger used to call the madman theory
Kissinger is going over to Paris to talk
to the North Vietnamese and Nixon says
Henry you tell him this Nixon's nuts
said he might hit the button and blow
them off the face of the earth he's a
madman and I'm having trouble
restraining him you
better make a deal soon and of course
the they they came to the table this is
exactly what Trump has done he's a he is
he is rattling the saber and all the
elitist foreign policy pukes were saying
oh my god this is he's he's gonna cause
World War 3 this is bombastic it's T's a
war monger no it brought the North
Koreans to the table why because they
understand Donald Trump's not a
creampuff like Barack Obama and when he
says there's a line in the sand
you're not gonna hop over it without
consequences Donald Trump is the
toughest person I've ever met I think it
was Roy Cohn who said it he pisses ice
water
the North Koreans do not want to
showdown with Donald Trump I agree with
that yeah right because when you when
you're threatening to nuke somebody and
they say well I have I have better
capability to do that's not a common
response from a US president I know it's
true and you know it's true but I said
when Reagan when Reagan referred to the
axis of evil yeah and they said that as
either the Soviets of the North Koreans
or somebody's I think the Soviets said
that being called evil frighten them
because when somebody sees you as evil
it's different than a political that
specific thing where he referred to them
as the axis is evil every single member
of the White House staff was opposed to
him saying that his speech writers were
opposed to it his cabinet was opposed to
it and he said no I'm saying it it's
going down in history as a catalyst for
their for their collapse they don't want
it they don't want to realize that
they're being dehumanized because it
makes now it's easier to blow you off
the face of the planet if we have to
because you're not a human evil they
want to have our moral equivalent don't
deserve it right plus the u.s. is always
known as being the ones who take the
high road and the u.s. so at least we
pretend to take the high road and I
think when a US president says some
we're not taking the high road
I think that's uncomfortable for people
and they think it's going to be a
problem well it's not so much the high
road is we're not going to keep bending
over in other words we've been giving
the Iranians and we've been giving the
North Koreans hundreds of millions of
dollars to try to induce them to behave
and then they don't behave and we don't
do anything about it who do you think is
the least flawed member of the Bush
family that would be very tough George P
Bush who is who has not only now been
accused of corruption in the management
of the state pensions funds where he
a railroad commissioner but also
screwing up the Alamo the the foundation
that runs the Alamo for the state o plus
allegations of sexual harassment in his
college days so he fits right into the
Bush plan yeah Prescott Bush the banker
u.s. senator made his fortune finance
the armaments for Hitler's Third Reich
oh my god he's a pip
yeah that's time George w HW trafficking
cocaine for the CIA really to pay
illegally for the Nicaraguan war running
it through a small town called Mena
Arkansas no problem there give the local
governor his cut and he'll keep his
mouth shut
why that would be Bill Clinton that's
why I'd be good Bill Clinton and also
all in the bush crime family available
on Amazon now Jeb is okay you know if
Jeb's IQ is one point lower you'd have
to water him he's actually very smart in
the book sense he's a policy nerd he
reads all this stuff yeah but he doesn't
know when to come in out of the rain
with his books getting wet well it's
like a noblesse oblige thing in other
words you're just supposed to serve me I
mean the the bushes are incredibly
disloyal people they came over on the
Mayflower to think the rest of us there
were peasants if you didn't go to Yale
or Harvard you don't belong to the
Council on Foreign Relations and the
Greenwich Country Club you can't be
anybody we only have free that's left I
want to make sure we plug Rogers booked
Rogers a great writer it's the New York
Times that he's a best-selling author
talking about this book let me just say
it my mother's recipe for marinara is in
there okay so you can dress properly you
can eat properly but it's actually a
really interesting book and its size
does matter rule 102 you're probably not
talking about what I think you're
talking about but I'm not okay talk
about the size your name should be on a
billboard or a poster always that matter
all you want is let your last names they
don't not for Congress vote on November
because people can only grab one thing
but didn't you know George Bush Senior
because you worked with Reagan he was
his vice president did you not like him
cocaine stuff he said I did not like him
I was in favor of
of Regan picking Jack Kemp from upstate
Buffalo as his running mate once he was
the Republican nominee of course I
supported him but I also knew that he
would undo reaganism as soon as he could
and he did remember when he said read my
lips no new taxes yeah and what did he
do he raised attacks the in fairness
that was that him who was at the
Congress in the Senate that kind of
screwed him and that was him it was him
Regan showed you could hold the line
with them but John Sununu and other of
the guys around Bush thought that there
was a an epic budget deal at hand if he
would just raise taxes this is the
functional end of reaganism this is a
return to the root canal Republican
Party of convinced voters were really
gonna hurt them but it's for their own
good what people will never buy what
about Neil Bush you mean the SNL guy who
stole millions in the SNL that guy is
that the one you think the one I was
thinking or is there Jeb who who had a
building that went into foreclosure on
which he owed four hundred million but
he got out with paying a dime I mean the
whole family is is epically corrupt
Donald Trump though has done some some
shady business stuff now Donald from the
president yeah not to my knowledge
oh all right never mind then bringing it
comes to ethics the Bush's Donald Trump
look like Rebecca of Sunnybrook farm can
you bring me to the White House I'd love
to have dinner with the president dinner
companion you're not a good I am solid
polite never madam appropriate times ya
know which way the bathroom is he put
you in a wrong direction what's really
maddening is when I take the Amazon or
the Barnes & Noble by link from their
site for this book four stones rule yes
and I post it on Facebook right or I
pasted it on Google sure and they
immediately knock it out as spam really
which they've never done on any of my
previous books so they're trying to make
it hard for me to sell which is why
people need to go to stones rules calm
stones rules calm and buy it there